All right guys, this is where the rubber meets the road. You can do all the previous steps
that we've talked about. You can pick the perfect city and the perfect niche. You can
build this great list. You can go and set up ads. If you do not call, if you do not
do this step because of whatever reason, whether you're scared, whether you tell yourself you
don't have time, it does not matter the reason. If you do not do this step, you will not make
money. You will not get deals. In order for you to close deals, you need to get people
on Zoom. In order for you to get people on Zoom, you need to send them leads. In order
for you to send them leads, you have to call them and get them hooked. In order to hook
them, you need to prospect them. You need to make the calls. Okay? Look, I understand
this part can be very intimidating. This part can be scary, but it's only scary because
you have been calling the wrong people. You haven't had the necessary scripts, which I'm
going to give you, and that's all about to change. A lot of you have seen other people
in this program that were terrified of the phone, that were absolutely doing everything
they could to avoid this one thing. Ironically, this is the one thing that is going to make
the difference between you making money and you not. I want to talk about why do we have
to do this uncomfortable step? Why can't we just skip it? Why this piece? Because this
is the part that everyone's the most scared of, so I want to talk about that really quick.
Number one reason why we have to do this is because this is the one thing that every other
agency owner out there avoids, and you watching this have been avoiding this most likely up
until now. You've done the email campaigns, you've done the messenger chats, you've done
Facebook posts and everything to avoid this thing. If you're avoiding it, every other
marketer is avoiding it. We all know there are programs out there that are trying to
teach you that you can get deals without cold calling. You can get deals by hiding behind
your computer. You can get deals with email drips. Guess what? Most of those things will
work to some extent. However, what I understand is that the things that people are unwilling
to do, if I do them, I am going to have massive success very quickly. Number one reason that
we're going to do this is because no one else wants to. My entire philosophy of life and
with this process is I want to zig while they zag. If everybody's doing this, I want to
do this because if everyone's doing something one way and most people are broke, I should
probably look the other way. Second reason, guys, money loves speed. I'm going to say
that a thousand times during this training and a thousand more times during my live calls
and a thousand more times in our conversations in the chat and one on ones. Money loves speed.
The quickest way to get to a business owner is not through an email, it's not through
a messenger, it's not through a this, it's through picking up the phone and calling the
person as long as we have the right number, as long as we're calling the right person.
This is the quickest way to get deals. I don't know about you, but the reason that I'm in
this, the reason that I discovered this process and I learned this process and I mastered
this process is because I wanted to speed it up. Guys, if you don't want to speed this
up, go do rank and rent. This is rent then rank. We're looking for speed. Money loves
speed. The reason why we're going to do this quote unquote, and I say quote unquote because
I promise you when you have the right scripts, you have somebody that knows what they're
doing because they've done it thousands of times and you're calling the right people,
this is not anything like cold calling as people define it. We are calling people who
are already interested in our product, who are already paying for our product from somebody
else more than likely and we're giving them results in advance with a script that works.
This is not scary, at least compared to knocking doors and selling home security systems, selling
vacuums, doing actual cold calling. The second reason we're going to do this quote unquote
uncomfortable step is because it's quick. It's fast. It gets us the yes or no as quickly
as possible so we can move on to the next so we can make money.
Third reason that we're going to do this uncomfortable, again, uncomfortable step is because it works.
It works and it always will. I believe one of the most barbaric old school things in
the world is going door to door. I do not believe in going door to door to door. I did
it for four years and you know what's crazy? As much as I don't believe in it, I think
there's so much better uses of your time than literally getting dropped off in a neighborhood
and going door to door to door with all the technology and the information that we have.
I do not think that's a good use of your time, yet it still worked, guys. It still worked
to the tune of me making hundreds of thousands of dollars in a summer and it is the most
barbaric method out there. What we're going to do is we're going to take the concepts
of that, which is direct to customer. We're going to go direct to customer, direct to
the business owner, but we're going to have some information. We're going to talk to only
people who are paying for leads, people who are already sold, and we're going to give
them results in advance. Two things I did not do when I did my barbaric method. This
works. When I say this, I mean reaching directly out. We're going to call it cold calling,
but I almost want you to think of this as warm calling. The third reason that we're
going to do this quote unquote uncomfortable step is because it works. The fourth reason
why we do this uncomfortable step, and I laugh every time I say uncomfortable because compared
to other stuff, this is not uncomfortable, but the fourth reason why we do this is because
we are in charge. We are in charge of, and we can control that we pick up the phone and
we dial a number and we call. I can control that. I can't always control if my email gets
blocked. I can't always control if the business owner looks at their message or whatever,
but when I pick up the phone and I call the phone number, I'm in total control. Now yes,
I guess technically you could say, well, they might not answer, but I'm telling you right
now 99% of the people that we're targeting, their personal cell phone is the one that's
listed on the business. That is how low, that is the type of caliber of people that we are
going after. We are going to be talking to most of these people directly to their personal
cell phone. I'd say 90% of the people you're going to call, you're going to be calling
their personal cell. You're not even going to be working, you're not even going to be
dealing with a secretary or a tracking number or any of that. Definitely not an 800 number.
We're talking directly to them. What I love about doing this is it puts us in control.
We can sit down every day and say, hey, I'm going to make X amount of calls and I'm not
going to have to worry about my email being blocked or this happening or my account being
suspended here. We are in control. We could pick up the phone and for some reason our
phone gets spammed out or whatever, it gets blocked. We can go get another number. It
allows us to be in control. So guys, this is the step. This is the part where if you,
this is the reality. If you do not do this step, you will not make money. So if this
scares you, good. If this process, if this part of the process frightens you, terrifies
you, welcome to the club. To this day, even me at this point, although this isn't near
as bad as going door to door, it still gives me the butterflies and it probably always
will and that to me just identifies, it just confirms that I'm doing the right thing.
So guys, let's jump in and let's freaking get a business owner on the hook.